بمحاوله اغتيال بوتين
الاشتباكات تشتد في السودان رغم تمديد
الهدنه
ومبلغ ضخم سيجلبه تتويج تشارليت الاقتصادي
بريطانيا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
نبدا من روسيا حيث اعلنت موسكو عن احباط
محاوله الاغتيال الرئيس عبر هجوم بطائرات
مسيره استهدف الكريم ملتهمه
بيان من اكد ان بوتين لم يصاب باي اذى وان
الجيش والقوات الخاصه عطلت المسيارتين
مشيرا الى ان شظايا الطائرتين تناثرت في
اراضي مجمع الكرمنين لكن لم تقع اصابه او
اضرار ماديه فيما نفت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه
لتهامات الروسيه قائله انك ليس لديها اي
علاقه بالهجوم على
موسكو اختلقت ذريعه لشان هجوم واسع على
اوكرانيا
روسيا احبطها محاوله اغتيال بوتين اطلقت
غياب وبعض مناطق وسط وشرق اوكرانيا اندرات
جويه كما طلبت رئاسه الاوكرانيه المواطنين
بالدخول الى الملاجئ فورا خوفا من هجمات
روسيه في المقابل طلب مجلس الدوم الروسي
بضرب مركز صنع القرار في كييف على الفور
لمحاولتها قتل بوتين على حد وصفه وسط
دعوات اخرى الى تنفيذ هجوم صاروخي على مقر
اقامه الرئيس المسكي كرد على ما حدث
والى السودان وبالرغم من الهدنه المعلنه
حلق طيران تابع للجيش فوق العاصمه الخرطوم
كما تجددت الاشتباكات في محيط القصر
الرئاسي
ومنطقه السوق العربيه المجاوره تجددت
الشباكات ايضا في محيط القصر الرئاسي
ومنطقه السوق العربيه المجاوره حيث تتمركز
قوات الدعم السريع مراسل العربيه افاد بان
قصفا بطائرات سمع في الخرطوم وام درمان
فيما تصاعدت اعمده الدخان في المكان مشيرا
الى ان الطائرات استهدفت مواقع للدعم
السريع بمحيط القصر الرئاسي والتي ردت
بمضادات ارضيه
في عمليه امنيه وسعه طاقه شجره الشرطه
الالمانيه حمله كبيره ضد اعضاء مافيا
ايطاليه تسمى نرجيتا ينتشرون في المانيا
الشرطه الالمانيه اوضحت في بيان لها انها
القت القبض على اكثر من 30 مشتبها به خلال
حمله مداهمات في انحاء البلاد مشيره الى
ان اكثر من الف شرطي شاركوا في تفتيش
عشرات المنازل والمكاتب والمتاجر في ولايه
عده فيما شارك بالعمليه التي اطلق عليها
اسم يوريكا شرطه ايطاليا وبلجيكا وفرنسا
والبرتغال واسبانيا
والى شغل في بريطانيا حاليا وهو حفل تتويج
الملك الثالث ملكا للمملكه المتحده الذي
قال عنه قاسم باكينغهام انه سيكون اكثر
الفاعليات التي شهدتها البلاد فخامه منذ
اكثر من جيل اللاسب في تصريحات القصر
مسؤول عن تنظيم حفل تتويج يقول ان ميء
سيحدث سيساهم في انتعاش اقتصاد البلاد وهو
ماء اوضحت وتقارير صحفيه اخرى واكدت ان
مراسم التتويج ستجني نحو مليار و250 مليون
دولار كما سيشارك 7000 من افراد القوات
المسلحه واكثر من 4000 فرقه موسيقيه